THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY
ALLEN ARAMBULA BAKER.
BERMAN BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHAVEZ
CHEN. DAVID CHIU CHOI. KANSEN
CHU COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY. DALY. EGGMAN
FLORA FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON. GLORIA
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GRAY GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN. IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA. MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA GRANNIS REVISE
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO. SALAS SANTIAGO
STEINORTH STONE. THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY.
TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE OF.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON.
GRADUATIONS LIKE SO MANY OTHER
RITUALS IN OUR LIVES ARE MARKING
MOMENTS.
FOR THE GRADUATE THE PARENTS AND
PARENT FIGURES AND THE COMMUNITY.
THEY SIGNAL BOTH A BEGINNING AND
AN END.
INCREASED RESPONSIBILITY AND
FREEDOM.
GROWTH AND UNCERTAINTY.
THEY ARE ALSO ABOUT LOVE.
THIS PAST WEEK I TOOK TIME TO
ATTEND THE GRADUATIONS OF MY
HUSBAND'S THREE CHILDREN.
AUSTIN JUNIOR. GRADUATED FROM
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL CAMINO
GRADUATED FROM MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
JAILING GRADUATED FROM HIGH
SCHOOL.
AS IT TURNED OUT. THESE
GRADUATIONS TURNED OUT TO BE
ANXIOUS EXPERIENCES.
AT EACH EVENTS I LISTENED TO
SPEECHES OF CHILDREN AND TEENS
TALKING ABOUT STRESS
FAMILY AND PEER PRESSURES.
OVERWHELMING FEAR. AND A
DETERMINATION TO LEARN WHO THEY
ARE AND ARE GOING TO BE.
HOW DO WE AS ADULTS
RESPOND TO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE SO
FULL OF ANGST?
AS IF THEIR CHILDHOOD HAS BEEN
COMPROMISED.
THESE GRADUATIONS WERE ANXIOUS
FOR ANOTHER REASON AS WELL.
AT EACH I WAS REMINDED THAT I AM
BOTH A WIFE. AND A STEPMOTHER.
A WELCOMED EXISTENCE FOR SOME
BUT STILL AN UNCOMFORTABLE
PRESENTS FOR OTHERS.
PARDONS ARE ALSO MARKING MOMENTS
THAT SIGNAL A BEGINNING AND AN
END.
THE AFTERMATH IS NOT OFTEN AS
PROGRESSIVE AS A GRADUATION.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THOSE WHO
ARE NOT INTERESTED IN YOU
BECOMING YOUR BEST SELF?
THE ANSWER IS THE SAME IN BOTH
INSTANCES.
YOU RESPOND IN LOVE.
THAT RESPONSIBLE ACT OF MEETING
FEAR WITH PATIENTS.
HATE WITH LISTENING.
AND STRESS WITH COMPASSION.
AS WILL GO THROUGH OUR DAY.
WORKING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
THE LIVES OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
COLLEAGUES STAFF FAMILIES IN OUR
OWN LIVES AND IN THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE WE WILL NEVER KNOW OR
MEET.
LET US TRY TO MEET EACH OBSTACLE
EACH DIFFICULT CONVERSATION ON
BILLS.
ON VALUES OR ONLINE.
OR EVEN AN ANGSTY GRADUATE.
WITH COMPASSION AND
UNDERSTANDING.
LET US TRY TO RESPOND TO
OURSELVES AND TO OTHERS IN LOVE.
THANK YOURSELF THEY WERE WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING. AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
PLEASE WHICH RIGHT OVER HARD
READY AGAIN. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
IT IS.
LEADING CAST.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO FRIDAY MAY TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN RECENTLY
MET AND IBM ARE ALL TODD GLORIA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEVEN IT'S
DISTRICT PRESIDING CHIEF QUICK
DEDUCTIBLES AND AT THE DESK
CATHERINE LUIS READ.
THIS ORDER CALDERON.
IS WALDRON SECONDS HAD THE
READING.
IT'S DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED
WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE TO
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS.
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE
.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES. FOR
THE DAY.
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF THE RENT AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL. MOTIONS
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ANYTHING
NAY TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE. AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
CARILLO QUIRK SILVA HAS BEGUN IN
GERMANY MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
OUT FOR OF THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO COMPETE TO COMMITTEE. SB
SEVEN NINETY FOUR STERN FROM
HEALTH COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE SB ELEVEN TWENTY ONE
DOT FROM THE PRIVACY CONSUMER
TEXACO MANY TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. AND THEN BACK TO THE
PRIVACY CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE S. B. TWELVE FIVE HILL
FROM THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEES OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
DOCTOR CHOI FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO
YOU RISE SIR. THANK YOU SPEAKER
AND THE MEMBER US MEMBER DOES
NOT.
THANK YOU SPEAKER OF LUCK TO
MAKE A MOTION THAT THE RULES BE
SUSPENDED AND ON AJ YA FORTY
REGARDING THE KOREAN PEACE
PROCESS BE REFERRED TO THE FLOOR
FOR IMMEDIATE ACTION.
THAT'S A MOTION TO SUSPEND THE
RULES THAT REQUIRES A SECOND.
SECONDED BY MISTER FONG.
MEMBERS THIS IS A MOTION TO
SUSPEND THE RULES.
DR CHOI IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE. THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE MEMBERS.
CARCLUB THEY'RE ALL MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR A NO.
NO DOCTOR CHOICE ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THIS IS A ROLL SUSPENSION.
IT TAKES FORTY ONE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR NO.
AND DOCTOR CHOI IS ASKING FOR
NINE.
IS TAKES FORTY ONE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL EYES TWENTY TWO
KNOWS
FORTY.
MEMBERS IF I COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION.
MISTER SPEAKER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED STAKE YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS EARLIER
TODAY WAS MY HONOR TO ADMINISTER
THE OATH OF OFFICE TO OUR NEW
COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
JESSE GABRIEL AND LOOSE REDUCE.
MANY OF YOU WERE ON HAND THIS
MORNING AND NO OTHERS OF TAKING
YOUR TIME IT TAKEN THE TIME TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT A CHALLENGE IT
IS TO START IN THE ASSEMBLY BUT
DARREN BUDGET WEEK.
ADDS AN EXTRA DEGREE OF
DIFFICULTY SO I HOPE ALL OF YOU
WILL JOIN IN JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING OUR TWO NEW COLLEAGUES
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. AND
I KNOW YOU OFFER THEM YOUR
SUPPORT AND FRIENDSHIP AS THEY
START THEIR JOURNEY
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS IN
THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER TODAY.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO MS
RANSOM IS REYES YOU HAVE GUESTS
WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
WHAT IS HERE TODAY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD WELFARE
COUNCILS?
COMMERCIAL SEX OR SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION OF CHILDREN ACTION
TEAM. ARE FIVE ORGANIZATION
STAFF AND THEY'D SURVIVOR
ADVISORY BOARD MEMBERS.
THE C. SET TEAM IS AT AN EXPERT
AT MULTI DISCIPLINARY BODY
DEDICATED TO RESEARCHING
IDENTIFYING. PROMISING
PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION
PRACTICES TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN.
THEY COLLABORATE WITH SURVIVORS
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO COUNTY
AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
AND CONDUCT EVALUATIONS TO
ENSURE POLICIES IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR OUR CHILDREN.
THEIR WORK IS OUTSTANDING IN
THEIR COMMITMENT IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF CHILDREN AFFECTED BY
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THE CALIFORNIA CHILD
WELFARE SEE SEC ACTION TEAM TO
THE ASSEMBLY
.
AND I BELIEVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW HAS GAS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY
MR LOW YOUR RECOGNIZE THAT YOU'D
ASK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY AS CHAIR OF
THE LGBT LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS TO
WELCOME. THE ENTIRE PALM SPRINGS
CITY COUNCIL.
THE CITY OF PALM SPRINGS MADE
HISTORY IN NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN WHEN ELECTED THE
FIRST ALL LGBTQ CITY COUNCIL IN
THE NATION.
THIS IS SORT FEE WAS DECADES IN
THE MAKING FOR TOWN OF FORTY
SEVEN THOUSAND. WHERE?
THE FIRST OPENLY GAY PERSON
ELECTED PROMISING CITY COUNCIL
OCCURRED IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE.
AND EIGHT YEARS LATER HE BECAME
THE PALM SPRINGS FIRST DAY
MARENOSTRUM THE CITY COUNCIL'S
FIRST LGBT MAJORITY.
OF THE PALM SPRINGS IT HOUSES
CURRENTLY LED BY MAYOR ROBERT
MOON MAYOR PRO TEM.
J. R. ROBERTS AND CITY MANAGER
DAVID READY THE PALM SPRINGS
CITY COUNCIL IS COMPROMISE OF
COUNCIL MEMBERS CHRISTY HOLES
SAGE COUNCILMEMBER JEFF COURSE.
AND COUNCIL MEMBER LISA
MIDDLETON.
A THIS SERVES AS A TESTAMENT TO
THE COMMUNITY I ASK YOU TO JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING THE ENTIRE
PROMISING CITY COUNCIL AND THE
REAR
EVERS WE ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE.
ON RECONSIDERATION ITEMS FOR
FIVE SIX.
AND SEVEN. WILL BE CONTINUED.
WE ARE ON THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE.
FILE ITEMS NUMBER EIGHT AND NINE.
PASS A RETAIN.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE NUMBER TEN.
IS FILE NUMBER TEN. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN.
HR ONE OH SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE OF SIX BY
SOME THE NUMBER HOLDEN AND
OTHERS BOLTED JUNETEENTH.
MR OLDING YOU MAY OPEN ON THE
RESOLUTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR
ONE NO SIX WHICH RECOGNIZES JUNE
NINETEENTH AS JUNETEENTH.
SINCE EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE
JUNETEENTH HAS BEEN A
COMMEMORATION OF THE ENDING OF
SLAVERY.
CELEBRATE ACROSS THE NATION IN
MANY COMMUNITIES.
THIS DAY SERVES AS A TIME TO
REMEMBER OUR HISTORY AND TO LOOK.
BACK AT WHAT WE CAN DO.
AND MOVING FORWARD TO HONOR OUR
FUTURE.
IN THE SAME LIGHT. WE'RE
REMINDED OF THIS GREAT TRIUMPH
OF FEEL I FEEL AN OBLIGATION TO
CARRY FORTH THIS LEGACY. SO THAT
OUR HISTORY IS NOT FORGOTTEN.
AS WE LOOK TO OUR PAST
WE RECOGNIZE THESE EVENTS AS
AMERICAN HISTORY. WHICH IS
SHARED AND FELT BY EVERYONE NOT
ONLY THOSE OF AFRICAN DESCENT.
WE'RE NOW BLESSED TO BE IN AN
AREA WHERE DIVERSITY CAN BE
CELEBRATED AND VARIOUS CULTURES.
AND VARIOUS CULTURES CAN UNITE
IN REMEMBRANCE OF THEIR HISTORY.
EACH DAY IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COME TOGETHER AND CELEBRATE OUR
DIVERSITY.
JUNETEENTH IS A DAY SET ASIDE
FOR ALL AMERICANS THIS YEAR IN
THE RICH CULTURE OF THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
THIS DAY IS MEANT TO CELEBRATE
THE TENACITY TO RESOLVE THAT AS
PRESIDENT IN THE CHARACTER OF
BLACK AMERICANS.
THOUGH WE HAVE OVERCOME THE
GREATEST OF OBSTACLES IN THE
PAST.
THERE IS AN ONGOING STRUGGLE TO
REACH TRUE EQUITY AND EQUALITY.
WE EVEN DOOR THE DEGRADATION OF
SLAVERY AND HAVE WORK TO REBUILD
OUR COMMUNITY AND BECOME LEADERS
IN THE NATION WE'RE WANTS
SUBJECT TO.
TODAY WE'RE NOT SIMPLY ASKING
FOR RECOGNITION ORG KNOWLEDGE
MINT. BORDER ENCOURAGING EVERY
AMERICAN TO UNDERSTAND THE
HISTORICAL CONTEXT OF WHAT THIS
DAY MEANS AND JOIN IN THE
CELEBRATION.
WITH HR ONE OH SIX
WE AFFIRM THE BLACK HISTORY IS
AMERICAN HISTORY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS HOLDEN MISS
CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER S. AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF I RISE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION
HONORING THE END OF A HORRIFIC
INSTITUTION OF SLAVERY.
JUNETEENTH PROVIDES US WITH A
POWERFUL AND SOBERING MESSAGE OF
ENDURANCE AND STRENGTH IN THE
FACE OF ADVERSITY.
FREEDOM WAS TOO LONG IN COMING
FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THE
UNITED STATES AND WE MUST NEVER
FORGET THE STRUGGLE OF LIBERTY
AND JUSTICE THAT MADE FINAL
EMANCIPATION POSSIBLE.
WE KNOW THAT THE CONSEQUENCES OF
SLAVERY STILL ECHO TO THIS DAY I
WITH AS WE STILL SEE PEOPLE.
THAT ARE BEING RIPPED APART FROM
THEIR FAMILIES.
AS A MEANS OF CONTROL AND
DISCRIMINATION.
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT A WE
COMMEMORATE THIS DAY AND
EMPHASIZE THE DIGNITY AND
ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
UNLIKE A CERTAIN HIP HOP ARTISTS
WHO CLAIM RECENTLY THAT SLAVERY
WAS A CHOICE WE KNOW BETTER.
WE KNOW. THAT THE CHAINS OF
OPPRESSION AND MARGINALIZATION
WERE LITERAL SHACKLES THAT BOUND
TO PEOPLE INTO CENTURIES.
A POVERTY.
IT IS ONLY THROUGH THE
LIBERATION OF ALL PEOPLE.
BILL WE CAN ALL TRULY BE FREE.
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
PASADENA FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION.
TO THE FLOOR AND I URGE YOU AYE
VOTE FOR HR ONE OF SIX
THANK YOU.
MAKING HIS GRIMACE LEVINE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
pSPEAKER AND MEMBERS I ALSO RISE
IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS FOR HR ONE OF SIX
IMPORTANT.
TO MARK JUNETEENTH AND HOW
IMPORTANT THIS WAS I BET THAT
THE EMANCIPATION PROCLAMATION
AND THEN THE FISCAL AUTHORITY TO
ACTUALLY FREE.
SLAVES WAS FOR ALL AMERICANS AND
OF COURSE FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
BUT IT IS ALSO. IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT FORMER SLAVES THAT DAY.
WE'RE NOT.
DELIVERED INTO FREEDOM.
AND LIBERATION THEY WERE USHERED
INTO AN ERA OF THE BLACK COATS
AND THE JIM CROW SOUTH.
AND IF YOU THINK THAT'S BEHIND
US.
OPEN YOUR EYES WE HAVE A WHOLE
LOT MORE TO DO.
AND SPUR SOME IT'S AS THOUGH
LINCOLN'SPROCLAMATION STILL HAS
YET TO ARRIVE I URGE ALL AND I
THE ONLY TRUE IN A SIX.
THINGS SURE LEVINE DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IS
A MEMBER OF THE CAUCUS AT THANK
ONCE AGAIN. OUR OUR LEADER OF
MISTER HOLDEN FROM PASADENA IN
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION FOR.
YOU A JUNETEENTH IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT DAY WAS HISTORICALLY
IN THE LIFE OF AFRICAN AMERICANS.
BECAUSE IT ENDED FOR AT LEAST
LEGALLY.
SLAVERY IN THIS COUNTRY.
BUT AS POINTED OUT IT ISSUED IN
A NEW ERA.
IN THAT ERA CONTINUES TO THIS
DAY IN DIFFERENT FORMS.
AND DIFFERENT METHODS AND
DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITY ACT OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR SO MANY.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ALSO
TO RECOGNIZE THAT EVEN THOUGH.
IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE WHEN
EMANCIPATION CAME AND WAS TOLD
TO THE LAST WEEK WITH PEOPLE AND
TEXAS THAT THEY HAD BEEN FREED
LEGALLY FREE.
THE RESIDUAL IMPACT OF THAT IS
STILL FELT.
AND I THINK LAST YEAR A TALK TO
YOU ABOUT A A WALLET THAT I SAW
WHEN I WAS AT THE MUSEUM.
AND HOW PRECIOUS FREEDOM WAS
BECAUSE IT WAS SO FRAGILE TO
THOSE WHO ARE WHO ARE IN SLAVE
AND THOSE WHO WOULD NOT ENSLAVED.
BUT IT ALSO HAS AN IMPACT ON
PEOPLE'S LIVES TODAY.
HOW'S THAT A BOOK CLUB YESTERDAY
AND WE WERE READING A BOOK
CALLED HOMECOMING BY THE AFRICAN
AUTHOR.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS OF THE
FAME OF ONE OF THOSE BOOKS WAS
THE ISSUE OF BELONGING.
AND UNDERSTANDING WHO YOU ARE.
AND I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FROM THE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
ONE.
AND THE MEMBERS OF HIS OF HIS
STAFF.
FOR HELPING US TO GET A LITTLE
BIT CLOSER TO UNDERSTANDING
THE IMPACT OF THAT SLAVERY HAS
HAD ON OUR LIVES.
YOU KNOW MOST OF YOU CAN BEGIN
TO TALK ABOUT YOUR FAMILY.
A YOU CAN TALK ABOUT HOW FAR YOU
CAN GO BACK AND YOU CAN REMEMBER
YOUR RELATIVES AND YOU HAVE
PHOTOGRAPHS WE HAVE PICTURES AND
YOU HAVE. ALL OF THIS STUFF THAT
HELPS YOU TO DEFINE WHO YOU ARE
AS A PERSON.
IF YOU'RE AN AFRICAN AMERICAN.
YOU'LL BE LUCKY TO KNOW YOUR
GREAT GRANDFATHER.
IF YOU'RE MY AGE.
OTHERS MAY KNOW THEIR GREAT
GREAT IF THEY'RE YOUNGER.
BUT THE ABSENCE OR THE ERASING
OF HISTORY AND HERITAGE.
IS SO PROFOUND.
THAT IT BECOMES DIFFICULT TO
HAVE A SENSE OF BELONGING.
A SENSE OF IDENTITY. AND KNOWING
WHO YOU ARE.
YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE IT'S ALMOST
AS IF YOU WERE AN ORPHAN.
YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE HOW FAR YOU
CAN GO BACK AND UNDERSTANDING.
BECAUSE THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
AMERICAN SLAVERY WAS AN ATTEMPT
TO COMPLETELY ERASE.
PASSED THE
THE HISTORY THE GREATNESS OF
AFRICANS IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO THAT THEIR FAMILIES WERE
SEPARATED AND DIVIDED NEVER TO
BE FOUND AGAIN.
AND ONE OF THE GREATEST THINGS
THAT HAPPENED AT THE END OF
EMANCIPATE OF OF SLAVERY WAS A
PEOPLE BEGAN TO LOOK FOR FAMILY.
AND THAT NUMBER PLAYS ABOUT
PEOPLE LOOKING FOR FAMILIES JOE
TURNER'S COME AND GONE IS ONE OF
THOSE BUT AUGUST WILSON.
AND IN THAT THERE'S ALWAYS THIS
SERVES TO TRY TO FIND WHO YOU'RE
PEOPLE WORK.
BECAUSE YOU WERE SEPARATED.
YOU MIGHT KNOW BROTHER SISTER IF
THEY HAPPEN TO REMAIN AT THE
SAME PLANTATION.
BUT THE LIKELIHOOD OF ACTUALLY
TRACING YOUR FAMILY BACK
IT'S DIFFICULT.
AND IT'S HARD TO EXPLAIN TO
THOSE WHO HAVE ALL OF THAT IN
THEIR PAST.
JUST HOW ABSENCE IT FEEL IN YOUR
HEART
BUT YOU DON'T KNOW THAT.
I WAS FORTUNATE TO CHEER TO
BASICALLY GET SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION NOT ALL OF IT.
BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW IT FELT
TO FOR WANT TO SEE MY GREAT
GRANDFATHER SPACE.
BUT I HAD NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
AND TO SEE A NAME ON A SINCE HIS
RECORD.
OF A GREAT GRANDFATHER.
AND HAVE SOME SINCE OF TRYING TO
PIECE THOSE PIECES TOGETHER BUT
I HAVE NEVER BEEN ABLE TO PIECE
TOGETHER.
I HOPE WE UNDERSTAND WHY I TALK
THE WAY I TALK.
WHY HAD THE PASSION THAT I HAVE
I KNOW IT COMES FROM MY PARENTS
BUT I ALSO WONDER DID IT COME
FROM SOME OF THEM?
THAT I GET SOME OF THIS PASSION
AND SOME OF THIS ELOQUENCE YOU
GUYS SAY I HAVE FROM SOME OF
THEM.
I DON'T KNOW.
AND SO IT'S THE LOS PIECES THAT
ARE IN OUR LIVES THAT SLAVERY
HAS TAKEN AWAY.
THAT WILL NEVER BE REPLACED.
AND SO I JUST WANTED TO SHARE
THAT WITH YOU BECAUSE WE OFTEN
TALK ABOUT THE CELEBRATION AND
THE ENDING OF SLAVERY AND THE
MOVING FORWARD AND THE
CHALLENGES OF JIM CROW.
BUT THIS OTHER PIECE THAT MAKES
US HUMAN.
IS THERE.
I CAN REMEMBER WHEN OF. ONE OF
THE AUTHOR HAD WRITTEN A BOOK
AND HE WENT TO THE FREEDOM OF OF
EGGMAN GHANA AND HE SAT THERE
AND HE WATCHED PEOPLE. WHEN GOT
I GOT ITS LIBERATION IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES.
HE SAID HE'S SADDAM LEBRON
BENNETT WAS THE AUTHOR HE SAW
THEM CRYING FOR THEIR FREEDOM
AND LOVE FOR THEIR COUNTRY.
AND HE SAID HE SAT THERE CRYING
FOR HIMSELF.
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T HAVE THAT DEEP
HISTORY.
AND THAT DEEP LOVE FOR AMERICA.
BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH A SHORT
HISTORY.
AND HE DIDN'T HAVE ALL OF THE
PIECES THAT MADE HIM AN AMERICAN.
IT'S I WANTED TO SHARE THAT SO
YOU UNDERSTAND WHO WE ARE.
UNDERSTAND THE ANGST BUT MORE
IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT OF SLAVERY.
AND THAT AS WE CAST THEM THINK
ABOUT IT WE SAY TO OURSELVES
NEVER AGAIN.
BECAUSE OF THE LONG TERM
PERMANENT IMPACT
IT HAS ON THE LIFE OF PEOPLE
WHEN YOU DEHUMANIZE THEM AND YOU
TAKE THEIR HUMANITY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR HR ONE ALL SIX.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT.
ON THE RESOLUTION MISTER HOLDING
YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND LET
ME JUST THINK ARE MY COLLEAGUES
WHO HAVE.
RISEN TO SHARE WORDS OF
ELOQUENCE.
AND A REFLECTION OF WHAT THIS
DAY MEANS.
A NOT JUST WHAT IT MEANS TO
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
COMMUNITY BUT WHAT IT MEANS TO
ALL OF US.
BECAUSE WE'RE INFLUENCE AND
IMPACTED BY HISTORY WHETHER IT
FELT.
SPECIFICALLY ON OUR PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY BUT IT HAD RIPPLES
ACROSS ALL OF OUR.
COMMUNITIES.
SO WE'RE ONE AMERICA SO WE HAVE
TO RECOGNIZE THE HISTORY AND THE
IMPACTS GOOD BAD AND INDIFFERENT
THAT IT HAS HAD ON ALL OF OUR
CAN.
SO THIS IS THE DAY FOR THEY
OFTEN AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO
REJOICE IN THE FACT THAT THERE
WAS AN INTO SLAVERY. YES THERE
WERE OTHER CHALLENGES THAT CAME
AFTERWARDS.
WE PERSEVERE.
TODAY.
WE COLLABORATE.
WE COME TOGETHER ON THIS FLOOR.
DEBATE ISSUES THAT IMPACT ON ALL
OF US.
SO WE ARE JUST PLEASED TODAY
THAT WE CAN LOOK BACK FOR A
MOMENT TO REFLECT ON.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED SO THAT WE CAN
LEARN NOT JUST?
ABOUT THE HISTORY OF THE PAST.
BUT THAT IT CAN ALSO.
PARIS TO HOW TO MOVE FORWARD IN
YOUR FUTURE MISTER SPEAKER I ASK
FOR THE FIRST RULE OF THE OPEN
FOR COLLECTORS.
THANK YOU MR HOLDEN THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE HOUSE RESOLUTION THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR COAUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR ONE
OF SIX.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SEVENTY SEVEN
CO AUTHORS ADDED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
I OPPOSE IN A. THE EYES HAVE IT.
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MISTER
HOLDING BACK TO YOU FOR YOUR
SPECIAL GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT IS A
PLEASURE AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE.
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS TO RECOGNIZE JOINING US
TODAY THE BLACK JUDGES WHO ARE
VISITING THE CAPITOL. ON THEIR
LEGISLATIVE DAY DURING THIS
DOING TEAM CELEBRATION. OF THIS
YEAR WE RECOGNIZE BLACK JUDGES
FROM ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FOR THEIR ROLE IN
UPHOLDING THE FREEDOMS WE HAVE
GAME THAT'S FAR AND CONTINUE TO
PURSUE.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME OF THE FORTY
THREE JUDGES THAT HAVE JOINED US
TODAY WHO ARE IN THE BALCONY.
GOOD RECOGNIZING
.
MR OUT HERE I'D LIKE TO ALSO
RECOGNIZE
OF THE
I INTRODUCE.
ON THE FLOOR.
WE LIKED IT.
AUDIBLE MICHAEL D. CARTER LOSS
AND
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE.
HOWEVER WILLIAM MURRAY THE THIRD
DISTRICT COURT OF APPEALS JUDGE
AUDIBLE BRENDA HARBIN FORTE.
ALAMEDA COUNTY COURT JUDGE
HONORABLE KEVIN BRAZIL LOS
ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT ASSISTANT
PRESIDING JUDGE AN HONORABLE
BOBBY THOMPSON TILLMAN. LOS
ANGELES COUNTY COURT JUDGE
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING OUR
HONORABLE.
BOB HERTZBERG
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KEVIN MCCARTY.
TOMORROW JUNE TWELFTH IS LOVING
DAY.
CELEBRATING THE NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN SUPREME COURT DECISION
STRIKING DOWN BANDS ON
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGES.
TODAY FIFTY ONE YEARS LATER WE
CELEBRATE THE DIVERSITY AND
EQUALITY OF ALL PEOPLE.
HAPPY LOVING DAY.
RECESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY JUNE TWELFTH CHECK IN
SESSION.
IN FLOOR SESSION UPON CALL OF
THE SPEAKER.
WEDNESDAY JUNE THIRTEENTH CHECK
IN SESSION OF FLOOR SESSION UPON
CALL THE SPEAKER. THURSDAY JUNE
FOURTEENTH FLOOR SESSION.
IS AT NINE AM IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED.
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR.
REMOVE YOUR CONVERSATION FROM
THE FLOOR THE ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
OR GIVE YOU RESPECTFUL ATTENTION
HERE COLLEAGUES WHO WILL BE
ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY TODAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
SO WE MAY PROCEED
.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR RESPECT.
TO MISS CARILLO MISS CARILLO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR A GERMAN
IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO HONOR
THE MEMORY OF JOHN OR PEACE.
A CHICANO ACTIVISTS AND FRIEND
TO MANY.
WHO PASSED AWAY ON MAY EIGHTH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN?
IS CONTRA RESUMES HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THAT YOU GOT A
LOCK OUTS WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN
THE ON GOING FIGHT FOR
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. OPPORTUNITY
AND JUSTICE.
A GRADUATE OF GARFIELD HIGH
SCHOOL IN EIGHTY FIFTY ONE AND
THE LEADER OF THE NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT YOU GOTTA WALK OUT.
JOHN HELPED SPARK THE NATIONAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE POSITIVE
CHANGE MADE POSSIBLE BY
EMPOWERING STUDENTS THROUGH
COMMUNITY ACTION.
THE TERM BLOW OUT WAS COINED BY
JOHN TO DESCRIBE THE ENERGY THE
WALKOUTS PRODUCE.
AS A JAZZ MUSICIAN HE SAW THIS
MUSIC A TERM USED TO DESCRIBE
THE STRESSING OF A PARTICULAR
NOTE. AS A WAY TO CHARACTERIZE
THE COLLECTIVE MOVEMENT HE
HELPED GENERATE ALONGSIDE FELLOW
CHICANO LATINO LEADERS.
JOHN WAS AMONG THOUSANDS OF
CHICANO STUDENTS DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST BY AN EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
OF THE NINETEEN SIXTIES.
STUDENTS WERE NOT ALLOWED TO
SPEAK SPANISH WERE FUNNELED AWAY
FROM COLLEGE PREP COURSES AND
HAD FEW TEACHERS OF COLOR WHO
COULD RELATE TO THEM.
INSTEAD OF ACCEPTING PEACE
UNFAIR CIRCUMSTANCES JOHN AND
HIS COLLEAGUES.
I STAND BY ADDRESSING INJUSTICE
THAN FOSTERING AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE DIVERSITY COULD DRIVE.
COLLEAGUES WE PREVIOUSLY HONORED
THE WORK OF JOHN ON PEACE AND
HIS FELLOW CHAMPIONS.
pAND YOUR YOUR PEACE. IN THESE
CHAMBERS IN MARCH.
IT WAS A POWERFUL MOMENT OF THE
HISTORICAL RECOGNITION AND LEFT
A DEEP IMPACT TO JOHN.
HE TOLD BOBBY AFTERWARDS IN MY
OFFICE.
THAT AFTER RECEIVING THAT
RECOGNITION FROM THE STATE
LEGISLATURE HE FELT THAT IT WAS
THE FIRST TIME.
BUT HIS WORK.
ACTUALLY MATTERED AND MADE A
DIFFERENCE.
JOHN'S WORK WILL NEVER BE
FORGOTTEN.
AND HIS IMPACT LIVES THROUGH THE
STUDENT LEADERS OF TODAY.
PASSIONATE DETERMINED AND READY
TO FORCE CHANGE NEEDED.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
RECOGNIZE HIM HE NOW JOINS.
WITH A LOCK OUT TEACHER AND
MENTOR SELL CASTRO WHO WATCHES
OVER US.
MAY HE REST IN POWER.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO MS QUIRK
SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS IN MY DISTRICT IS OFTEN
CALLED. THE EDUCATION COMMUNITY
WITH THREE UNIVERSITIES CAL
STATE FULLERTON CYPRESS COLLEGE
AND FULLERTON COLLEGE ACTUALLY
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND.
WITH THAT NOTE WE ARE
RECOGNIZING TODAY DOCTOR DON
* WHO IS THE FORMER CYPRESS
COLLEGE PRESIDENT AND ONE OF THE
CAMPUSES FIRST.
EMPLOYEES WHO PASSED AWAY ON
MAIN NINE.
HE SERVED TO ENTER IN TERMS AS
THE CAMPUS LEADER WAS DEEMED A
VICE PRESIDENT AND MAINTAIN
INVOLVEMENT AT THE COLLEGE
FOLLOWING HIS RETIREMENT.
HE WAS NINETY ONE YEARS OLD
DOCTOR BERNARD IS ALSO KNOWN AS
MISTER CYPRESS COLLEGE BECAUSE
OF HIS SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT AND GROWTH OF
CYPRESS COLLEGE. HE WAS AT
CYPRESS COLLEGE FROM THE
BEGINNING AND CONTINUED CREATING
A PATH TO SUCCESS FOR STUDENTS
WELL INTO HIS RETIREMENT.
HE WAS AN ARMY VETERAN DOCTOR
BERNARD CAME TO CYPRESS COLLEGE
WHEN THE CAMPUS OPENED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX FOLLOWING A
K. TWELVE CAREER IN WHICH HE
SERVED AS A TEACHER. COUNSELOR
AND A VICE PRINCIPAL AT ORANGE
HIGH SCHOOL AND A PRINCIPAL AT
LAGUNA BEACH
HIGH SCHOOL.
DOCTOR BERNARD WAS THE FATHER OF
SIX CHILDREN LAURIE RENAME
MICHAEL DAYNA CURRY AND A NET
AND. WE.
SAY A PRAYER FOR HIS LOSS
THANK YOU.
BOTH OF MISTER SPEAKER HAD
ANOTHER A CITIZEN FROM FULLER
TEN THAT WILL BE MESSED HE WAS
SOMEBODY WHO I MET ALMOST
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO DOCTOR COUP
ó WAS BORN ON MARCH. FIFTH
NINETEEN FORTY ONE IN SEOUL
KOREA AND PASSED AWAY ON MAY
FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND FULLER
TEN.
HE IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED
STATES IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX AND
GRADUATED WITH A BACHELORS OF
SCIENCE IN BIOLOGY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY. HE WENT ON TO EARN A
MASTER'S DEGREE IN BIOLOGY AND
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO FROM LOS
SIERRA UNIVERSITY. HE LATER
EARNED HIS DOCTORATE OF DENTAL
SURGERY AT THE SCHOOL OF LAW
MELISSA. LOMA LINDA. UNIVERSITY
AND HE.
SET UP A PRACTICE IN FULLERTON
GAVE A DENTAL PRACTICE FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS HE WAS NO ONE FROM
HIS PATIENTS AS MEAN NORMALLY
VERY FRIENDLY BUT MANY OF US.
ALSO CAN IDENTIFY WITH THE FEAR
OF GOING TO A DENTIST AND HIS
PATIENCE LEFT SMILING AND HAPPY.
HE ALSO UP BECAME A COMMUNITY
LEADER NOT ONLY AN ORANGE COUNTY
BUT THROUGHOUT LA AS A WE ALL.
WATCH WITH THE RIOTS IN LOS
ANGELES DOCTOR WHO STEPPED UP
AND MADE IT A POINT THAT HE
WANTED TO BRING COMMUNITIES
TOGETHER HE WORKED UP VERY. MANY
DECADES WORKING TO BRING.
LATINO COMMUNITY VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY AND CHINESE
COMMUNITIES TOGETHER THROUGH
CELEBRATIONS AND COMMUNITY
DIALOGUE. AYE HE WAS ASKED ABOUT
THE RIOTS AND HE SAID THAT HE
REALIZED DURING THAT TIME IT WAS
ESSENTIAL THAT WE LEARN TO REACH
OUT TO OUR NEIGHBORS AND
COMMUNICATE.
UP THROUGHOUT THAT HE CONTINUED
HIS WORK.
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY NOT ONLY
BECOMING INVOLVED AND CAMPAIGNS
AND ELECTIONS WHICH IS HOW I MET
HIM. I AND HE LEAVES BEHIND A
AND IS SURVIVED BY HIS LOVING
FAMILY HIS WIFE MYONG SOON ó
HIS SON CHRISTOPHER O.
CHRISTOPHER'S WIFE YOU JIAN. HIS
GRANDSON DELANO GRANDDAUGHTERS
MADELINE AND EMILY HIS SON JAMES
O. AYE HIS.
AND HIS WIFE SANDY ALSO
GRANDDAUGHTERS JESSICA AND
TIFFANY AND HIS DAUGHTER HELEN
CAM AND SON IN LAW JAY JASON CAM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAIN NO MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
TO ADJOURN MISTER COOLEY MOOS
MISS CARILLO SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY JUNE FOURTEENTH
AT NINE AM. WE ARE ADJOURNED